craig wow i barely recognize you out of
your guard uniform i need twenty
thousand dollars for a down payment on a
piece of swamp lamp are you applying for
a loan yeah i'm an advocate for black
people it's important you know that
because i can't give you a loan i've
worked on that presentation for over a
year this is your life gregory you got
to take action
i don't have much right now
i have no car
i called the fire department my home is
a 24-hour gym
hey camille
marco i got offered a new job in
columbus ohio you're not taking my
daughter to columbus they don't even
have a sports team they have the blue
jackets you are not making my daughter a
hockey fan
doing the right thing is never a mistake
i believe in karma what about nemo's mom
and finding nemo do you think she got
what was coming to her we don't know
what nemo's mom did before the movie
started we don't know how she was
you don't have to worry i'm not one of
those weird uber drivers that doesn't
talk oh
sorry i just have to do one thing what's
the hammer for henry
would you mind sliding down attacks no
no
so you're probably wondering about the
snake yeah that's exactly what i'm
wondering about
burmese typhoons eat everything it's an
ecological disaster so the state pays
for every dead pipe and we bring in
whoever gets the most snakes wins you 20
thousand dollars did you want to team up
i'm tough don't you hear my rugged
australian accent okay
i put that work in now watch me work
[Music]
are you okay i nailed the snake to my
hand at least you didn't feel any pain
[Music]
there is some very intense competition
look at this old-timer fly just lands on
his eye it's a hunting technique any
second he's going to snatch her out of
the air
that guy's so old insects think he's
dead
[Music]
you